things to know about Ron DeSantis number
one he's not Donald Trump the two men
seem to loathe each other these days and
are now both vying for the Republican
nomination for the white house yet they
were once close Trump helped Propel
desantes he was re-elected Florida's
governor by a landslide in 2022. number
two his education is about his
establishment as it gets Yale where he
was captain of the baseball team then
Harvard number three he was in the Navy
and served in Guantanamo as a military
lawyer and in Iraq too with the Navy
Seals University friends say he fancied
himself as Tom Cruise number four he
hates covered restrictions and resisted
master lockdowns and death rates in
Florida well they were less than those
in mandated States like New York and New
Jersey and number five there is nothing
he hates more than wokism so he takes on
the liberal left at every turn he's
removed books from schools which he says
are inappropriate he's banned abortion
after six weeks and he's picked a bitter
legal fight with Disney